五财人
这里是大舞老师的财经播客。
大家好欢迎来到五财人。
我们这一期的嘉宾是贾康老师。
我们经常会有一种感受。
每天能看到很多的宏观经济数据。
也经常听到积极的财政政策。
宽松的货币政策
扩大内需 提振消费等等这样的词语。
但是这些政策到底是什么意思。
和我们有什么关系。
其实很多时候普通人很难找到一个真正听得懂的答案。
这也是我为什么这一期会请到贾康老师的原因。
那贾康老师本身曾经长期担任财政部财政科学研究所的所长。
那也是中国财政科学研究院的博导。
同时他是中国财政体制和宏观经济政策研究的重要的学者。
贾康老师今年已经72岁了。
但是实际上你和他聊天的过程中。
你很难感受到那种宏观经济学者常有的距离感。
我们虽然聊的是宏观经济。
聊的是政策方向
但因为是贾康老师。
所以这个过程中其实也让我感受到了不少轻松 坦率。
甚至是有些可爱的时刻。
那这一期我们就从今年被网友称为史上最近的618开始。
我们一起聊聊说
为什么现在中国人不敢花钱了。
我们感受到的宏观数据和普通人的体感。
为什么会出现经济温差。
以及最重要的是
我们究竟还要等多久才能够真正感受到经济的挥暖。
那接下来就让我们进入本期的节目。
贾康老师今年其实618结束之后。
大家体感上从消费者的角度。
感觉到好像很安静。
也没有起到什么太大的火花。
然后包括平台也没有像往年一样不断的公布成交记录。
所以大家整体的感受是好像618就这样。
悄无声气的就过去了。
然后另一方面我们看到说。
5月的设定同比下降了0.6%。
就这两件事放在一起干。
我们的感觉就是说好像大家既没钱了。
也不想消费了 是不是这样一个情况。
这值得好好地在分析和跟踪。
618它现在不热闹的。
其实前面几年已经表现出这个趋势了。
包括1111光棍节。
总体来说热度逐年是往下调的。
跟618有相似之处了。
它表现的就是公众在嘉年华市的那种促销特定节日。
有感觉力的主题的这个轨道上面。
它已经形成了一定的收敛趋势。
大家并不是那么简单的。
按着一开始的那种。
其实上有一个叫洋群效应的态势。
大家就一蚊而入了。
当然也体现着就是消费经验积累以后。
这几年总体来说
消费是越来越讲究更多的做点精打细算。
更多的做一些理性考虑。
但5月份这是一个不符合意愿的现象。
一季度总体的宏观指标还是表现的亮色。
但为什么5月消费投资数据上都有值得警惕的下行。
这个方面的分析
我觉得可能还得注意一些带有风向标特点的一线城市。
像上海北京消费这方面。
法律其实已经有一段时间的表现。
最新的数据还在印证。
就是全国算下来的消费的下降的幅度。
要放到这种一线城市里。
它表现的比全国的水平要更大。
但同时也有一个值得进一步的分析认识的情况。
就是在上海
它另外一端的
其实跟消费或者有人认为跟投资也有关的住房。
却出现六年以来的最好的5月。
就是成交量上升
热度在一般的大家观察到的前面已经逐步回暖情况。
这样它还在加码
还在往上升
那要按着经济学分析来说。
这就变成了一个K型分化。
有一边感觉到消费行为形成的消费数据是下行的。
但是高端的有够买力的。
它这边还要往上走。
一个K型的分化
当然这个背后就反映着。
总体来讲
中国的老百姓
他有这种高中收入。
中低收入
低收入之间的明显的差别。
低中收入群体可能更多的要考虑。
精打细算
而中高收入以上的。
仍然有他们自己的那种抓住机会就出手的消费行为特征。
特别是中国人一向特别看重的好房子。
在这个市场的这种情况之下。
有这种分化非常值得我们综合的考虑。
怎么样进一步的优化。
总体的政策配套
当然这里边我想讲。
就是在面上而言
因为毕竟大多数的社会成员还是。
中等收入和中低收入。
也包括一些低收入。
他们在消费行为上的区域越来越谨慎。
确实得承认跟预期有关。
如果能够更好地做好预期管理。
是大众特别中低收入消费者。
他们的预期稳定和向好。
那么我觉得有助于进一步的调整消费潜力。
较正现在的
其实跟中产阶层以下。
特别中低收入阶层的消费特别谨慎。
有关的这种我们不愿意看到的趋势。
您刚刚提到说
可能有钱人还在买房子。
但是没钱人已经在谨慎消费了。
是不是能理解为这个贫富差距在扩大。
前一年已经形成的贫富差距。
就是最近一段时间的消费差距。
是不是仍然没有明显的得到缩小。
就是以前形成的贫富差距。
它还持续存在着
对的
当然了这跟市场上面。
大家感受到的就是温差业有关系。
因为老百姓平常而如沐染听到的。
很多消息不仅是咱们一些官方信息。
渠道说到的亮点
也听到了一些企业的困难。
听到了一些企业感觉无可奈何。
有那种前沿的高歌猛进的案例。
庞州六小龙之类
但确实有数量上可能更多的一般的企业。
感觉总是摆脱不了困难处境。
甚至说只能躺平
一些原来的老板们。
大多数是中小老板。
自己生产经营不行。
甚至最后走到了关闭工厂。
自己当自由职业者去了。
小老板去开滴滴了。
这种情况大家听到了以后。
自然就说我是不是也得谨慎一点。
我也慎着点是吧？
也不像过去那样
特别看买的时候要怎么样的。
有名牌买了以后
大家说起来是什么样的这种。
带点多少炫耀一下的社会氛围。
所以大家不关心
说你不说买的是不是名牌。
大家都自己越来越仔细的想。
我是不是买的核算。
但是我自己只能是观察。
年轻的朋友们可能另有特点。
年轻的消费主体
他一方面在有一些地方。
他也经大西藏
另外也消灭
他很愿意跨钱
比如说情绪消费
一些热闹的场所
文理与这方面的参与。
还是相当积极的
但是参与的过程中间也出现了。
就是人次在增加
人均消费控制的相对低。
就是大家现在就是花小钱。
然后买点快乐
买快乐很重要
老百姓终于找乐子。
这是可以考虑的
就是老百姓美好生活的需要。
他随着一个一个阶段。
他有这种消费组合和消费特征的变化。
我也听到一个评价。
我没有去说北京有环球影城。
人都拥在这里边
对 是
而心里消费起来好像灰金如土不在乎。
主要是里面的吃
然后还有酒店
然后包括买那些周边冻鬼。
还是中高档的消费。
就是你去一次怎么也得一两千。
这又是印证了我说的这个K型。
就是社会人有那么一层。
中高收入以仓的人。
在中国这么大的技术里。
这一部分人绝对数也不少。
他们可以继续拥入环球影城。
享受中高档的一些消费活动。
这就跟普运带来感受到的。
数据上讲的消费是下滑的。
又形成了一个堆招。
但是像您刚才说
现在大家的消费预期不足。
所以影响了消费能力。
那讲的是面上
对
大面上毕竟中产和中等收入。
接层以下的人是占14亿人口。
中间的多数
当然这种预期不足。
好像一方面是
就是大家可能收入确实下降了。
另一方面是自己的资产缩水了。
因为房地产整个市场不景气了。
甚至像我这几年
我的收入并没有变少。
就差不多维持不变。
但是我依然能感觉到。
我的消费预期降低了。
就是因为心理防备的。
预防性储蓄的动机。
无形中的提高
对
而且就是因为你的资产缩水了。
就虽然我可能也没有卖房子的需求。
但是你会觉得说
我的预期的钱会变成。
原来我那房子值1000万。
你变成800万了。
对
相当于亏了200万。
就是这种心情
有这个问题
它影响了人的消费的动机。
和实际出手的消费行为。
是啊？
但是你说现在房地产这个市场。
就是这部分假的资产缩值。
其实是很难改变的。
那在很难改变的情况下。
但你得注意
现在中国房地产市场总的来说。
就是很多人不愿意承认的。
是越来越都有热点。
你看最近的几期
中国房地产报报的全是。
上海房地产回暖
北京前一段时间已经回暖。
成都
武汉
包括东北的一些中心区域。
才是房地产是回暖的。
那么从你来说的资产缩水。
这个威胁在这些地方。
应该是明显的减少。
对
但是房地产回暖
可能也是一线城市的一些核心的地区。
一线和一些好的省会城市。
中心城市
特别是好地段
好楼盘
是的
所以就是很多没有在一线城市。
核心地段
买房子那部分的资产。
其实是肯定是
还是不行
对
大量的所谓三四
有人说还有第五档的。
是的
三四五线的感受还是不行。
那这种资产缩水的情况下。
而且收入可能在现在大环境下。
也很难有什么提高。
甚至你能保住自己目前的工作。
就不错了
这也就跟我前面说的预期连在一起。
大家不是觉得好像真的无所顾忌的。
我就考虑以后有光明前景。
说未来会不会有些威胁因素。
不利因素
自然而然在消费上面就要收敛。
是的
那怎么办呢？
那就得看总体我们怎么样叫做。
底利前行
认识适应和引领新常态。
这是过去的说法
新常态的心就是速度。
下调的过程中间
我们追求高质量
要落在一个相对稳定的。
由新入常的中高速运行。
高质量发展区间
其实这个事情
现在还有待最后确认。
我们四度现在回落的这几年。
就是百分之五
或者百分之五左右。
提的4.5到5
争取更好结果就比不再高一点。
实际怎么样
老百姓他有一个切身体验的过程。
我觉得中央特别强调的。
就是各种政策
要跟宏观政策保持一致性。
这非常重要
宏观政策最主要的什么？
要抓发展硬道理
坚持改革开放大政方针。
党的经济建设备中心的基本路线。
创新为第一动力
发展和安全统筹
稳中求尽已尽促稳。
这个大事如果真的能够实现出来。
老百姓的预期
总体的自然然会跟着向后。
但现在确实有一些扰动因素。
感觉有一些地方的传出的消息。
不是跟中央总的取向一致的。
宏观政策他有不一致的地方。
比如前一段时间
种种原因
地方政府困难
搞出远洋捕捞来弄得人形惶惶。
远洋捕捞就是这个距离。
了解了一些相关情况。
有把人家异地的企业家。
当然都是兼软是子孽的。
民企业家抓过来控制住。
让人家出钱
这是完全违背了
我们现在中央所说的稳中求尽。
和宏观政策保持一致。
是一种行为的不当扭曲。
损害总体的市场信心。
危害整个的预期管理。
这种消息一出来
作为老百姓心里就觉得恐慌。
而且的确实承认
就是这几年因为种种原因。
就是地方政府困难是比较普遍的。
过去说的发达地方还过得去。
现在传出一些发达地方也吃紧。
这还得承认这个现实。
中央已经采取措施了。
比如财政方面实行更加积极的财政政策。
货币政策配合为适度宽松。
双松搭配
那么这是一种超常规的。
就是强扩张的政策设计和政策贯彻中间。
要给经济的颈期法上拓。
在这种情况之下
我们更要珍惜这种政策导向。
带来的回暖的因素。
你如果跟宏观认识不保持一致。
那么可能不经意的某一两个案例。
他的连锁反应就是。
好事不出门 坏事传千里。
大家都觉得有威胁因素。
你说六小龙那么生终活虎。
很多人觉得跟自己比较远。
我也不是科技经营。
我也不是支持科技经营的金融经营。
我够不着什么特别的实惠。
但是我自己身边的那些东西。
好像又提不起气了。
再听到一些风风雨雨的。
这些违反中央大政方针的。
不保持宏观认识和一致性的这种信息。
自然就非常不利于信心的稳定和提证。
以及消费行为的向好。
我觉得您说的舆论确实很关键。
是一方面一个是觉得AI那么景气。
但是跟我没什么关系。
我这些普通人从AI那我也挣不着啥钱。
另一方面可能是一些这些信息。
不管是房子一直降价。
还是有一些政府的违规。
都让大家觉得说好像整个市场都没钱了。
但是这个只是表象。
我觉得就是底层还是说大家手里确实没钱了。
是吗？
你看地方政府也困难。
很多企业家现在也困难。
这困难有连带关系。
一定要领会中央的精神。
要采取务实的措施。
化解这些不利因素。
措施能不能说得具体点。
就您说财政政策货币政策具体的落实。
到时候到底是干啥。
你看财政政策现在几大重点。
首先是倚债化债
以规范的地方专项债。
五年为期
前三年为重点
现在已经在进行过程中举的一些进展。
要把已经真别清楚的14.3万亿地方的隐形债。
它的风险把它化解掉。
这样一来
实际上解脱了很多的地方政府和地方政府。
不能够兑现的应付款困住的企业。
这个事情还在继续推进的过程中间。
另外就是要支持作为国民经济支柱的房地产业。
让它能够稳下来
现在已经看到一些成效。
比如我前面提到的。
风向票作为一线和一些中心城市省会城市。
确实是在向后
但是它还有一个过程。
另外大量感受到的三四五线城市的不利情况。
那个扭转的阴城实测。
那可能有一个区别的逐渐的波浪式的一个演变过程。
再有就是货币政策适度宽松。
适度宽松在最早说24年924。
货币政策放大
然后是我们的非常敏感的股市。
至少是重挥4000点。
还在剧烈认当
这一段我也注意到了。
过了4000年以后。
升升降降的
大家还是很关注
当然了
毕竟货币政策
它是在这方面起了一个。
通过扩张
通过资本市场进一步的。
实际上有政策支持的。
这样一套组合权
起到了把经济景气的影响的不利因素。
做化解的正面效应。
这些还要继续做
但我感觉更深层的就是。
前面说到的财政政策货币政策是快变量。
它几个月的实质可能就见效。
或者说还可以加码。
但它毕竟不是说只靠政策。
就能够解决标本兼制而治。
治本为上
这样利益
种战略策略组合里边的最关键的问题。
最关键的问题还是要贯彻。
二十些三中全会
确定部署的300多项改革任务。
改革那就是慢变量了。
它确实到了深水区。
攻坚可难不容易
但是我觉得这个慢变量是关键性的。
就是你改革
如果真的能够按照领导人所说。
成为我们现代化的关键意招。
成为我们实际上的最大红利的来源。
那就是它贯彻的一开始改革开放。
那个基本的宗旨
持续的解放生产力。
现在叫培植发展新制生产力。
越牵涉的上台阶势的实现高质量发展。
追赶前沿
这个改革是难
但一定要抓住无妨。
您说那改革的重点是新制生产力。
是要解放生产力培植和发展新制生产。
新制生产的特点是什么？
就是它不是常规发展。
它是上台阶势的
越牵涉的发展
这才能使中国在总体来说。
追赶的过程中间逐渐的缩小和发达经济的距离。
新制生产力就是还是那些高精尖的。
直观的表现就是科技低生产力带着的。
现在到了信息革命时代里边。
从互联网家推进到AI家。
但是在中国
你说为什么这么多年注重科技新国。
我们从1到100的这种成果比较明显。
但是从0到1的成果发展可成。
什么道理
就是说你得承认我们的一些科技教育体制。
改革不到位的这种弊端。
抑制了中国人聪明材质发挥的潜力空间。
它是我们的这种真正的原创性的成果。
迟迟不能出来
是
前学生之论迟迟不能很好的破解。
对
那这就是改革慢变量。
就是还得从教育整个的体系。
什么高考这方面来改革 对吧？
包括老大男人问题。
你说高考大学怎么办。
这一听更慢了
你说西方那种各个学校自己命题的高考。
中国不行
那可能就是乌远人仗气。
拉关系处关系 是吧？
虽然有一些小口子。
后来发现这个口子不敢再大了。
总体上还是得统一命题。
统一命题就是逼大家来都是硬实教育。
这个什么？
大家比拼
孩子不能说在西炮县上。
比拼结果就是孩子的。
他的一些有创造性潜力的东西被压抑。
甚至有人说
孩子到了一定阶段以后。
黄金石断过了以后。
他那个创造潜力就被窒息掉了。
这种情况我们可能也得重视。
但是怎么样真正把这个。
毕竟还是有它的公平性的高考。
引到我们更合乎人才培养的。
新的境界上去
现在可是真的批评多。
正面的
建设性的这种思路并不清晰。
就是大家意识到这个问题了。
但是没想出什么特好的招来。
讨论多年
没跟AI讨论讨论。
科技体系里也是这个问题。
你得承认中国有这么多的投入。
是吧？
现在我们的学校
我们现在科研机构。
在经费方面是得到了。
前所未有的支持的。
你看中国现在虽然讲。
资金紧张什么的
各地的学校不要收名牌。
就是一般的
就是一般的职业教育的场所。
硬件往往都是国际上面。
一点也不逊色的
我去了欧美看了很多人家的校园。
人家的硬件
我们国内的我见到的各地的。
包括中学城市的这个校园。
硬件应该讲一般都不差。
但软件如何
这是后面要解决的问题。
你自己的失资
你自己老师教育这方面。
怎么样能够体现
就是教育能够不光给出知识。
而且给出他的思考能力。
创造能力
这篇文章非常大
但是这个关系到整个中国。
老百姓特别看重孩子。
能不能够成长
孩子能不能成长
现在大家还是在努力的说。
不输在起跑线上
我要给他参加这个班。
参加那个武习
这跟现在的消费的又有联系了。
这些年的体验就是。
一定要把孩子以后成财的这个。
可能出现的支出
这方面的资金储备。
做得更充实一些
这叫预防性储蓄
所以他越来越多
大家都预得都体会到了。
我自己消费
我给稍微更多的精打细算一些。
供孩子以后成财的这个储备。
我是一定要盯着的。
所以就不生了干脆。
那年轻人就讲了
这孩子我养不起了。
对呀？
宁肯就订可家庭算了。
那这种倾向也是表现的。
中国现在的少子的话。
跟老丁话同时发生。
中国的人口的替代率。
已经到了极力的水平。
这也是整个宏观上面。
必须通贪考虑的问题。
那我现在就听下来。
这像一个恶性循环。
就是我们现在
我们要警惕
不要落入恶性循环。
就是我现在就没钱。
没钱我们的方法是说。
发展新的生产力
就需要你培养
从小培养创造力
就需要教育改革
但是现在教育改革又没招。
没招了
它要影响这些家长。
所有的你有孩子的没孩子。
影响他们的整个消费预期。
让他们又不敢生
不敢生孩子就少了。
孩子少了以后的发展就更没有人了。
这不就是陷入了一个死互痛。
小五我发现你这个思路非常清晰。
就是这样一个可能性。
当然我们不能说真的就陷入恶性循环。
就没有办法了
但是要警惕
你现在很清晰的沟化的。
环环相扣的
福利因素合在一起。
要它使这种恶性循环成为一个主导因素的话。
那我们就没有前途了。
我们现在做的努力。
就是一定要防止真的形成这种恶性循环。
制标的政策方面层面已经非常清晰了。
资本方面的这个慢变量。
以老六十条 新六十条为代表。
都是有阶段性的部署的。
三百多项改革任务。
怎么样贯彻落实
这种改革肯硬无头。
把制度机制调好
把激励和约束搞对。
那我们的发展就有可能。
虽然直观上来讲告别高速发展阶段。
进入中高速
但是不跌破中高速的底线。
而同时能实现高质量的发展。
高质量包括着我们的硬件。
还有包括我们的软件。
也包括我们的人才培育。
包括我们社会成员。
中华民族14亿规模的。
特大规模经济体的这个。
所有的人都能够一起。
走向提升国民素质。
走向共同富裕的这个轨道上。
这就是我们前途所在。
这里面我的作为研究者强调的。
还是标本监制 质本为上。
就是看到现在政策的政策相运同时。
还要鼓励大家
要有肯硬无头精神。
在改革方面要敢于肯硬无头。
所以现在就是把球丢给了。
这些政策的制定者。
他们得肯硬无头对吧？
政策制定者之外
还有他的执行者
允许改革犯错误
但不允许不改革
都是写入文件的
但在具体执行中央到地方。
各级各个机构
各个地方辖去
他到底怎么样动真格。
这就不容易了
听起来还是挺难的。
实际生活中
我们感受到了很多的。
确实要承认的惰性因素。
像原来李克强总理专门说。
我怎么官场不为
有官而不为
为官不为
我觉得并不能简单的。
指责地方干部的绝务。
具体接触下来
中国这么多的地方基层干部。
他们很辛苦
但是由于改革往往不到位。
他们很多东西做的。
还是表面功
形式主义 官僚主义。
这方面的惰性因素还是到处可见。
对啊？
等下先保住自己的饭碗再说。
他们也有这个问题。
它不是简单的绝务问题。
整个一个制度机制。
怎么样鼓励这种改革创新者。
真正能够把他们这种。
主观的意愿变成实际的行为。
领导人说
为改革创新者胜
但是一线的改革创新者。
他现在越来越多的感觉就是。
一旦要改革
他就必须冲破一些条条框框。
这条条框框的现在。
大多都是有白纸 黑字的。
依据的
你如果多按白纸 黑字来做。
一般来说就可以明哲保身。
但是就谈不上创新突破了。
创新突破一定要试错。
你如果完全都按照白纸 黑字。
你可以标榜说我这全面依法治国。
我经得住审计 经得住巡视。
经得住方方面面的这个考察。
但是恰恰就是在真正需要去试错。
创新弹性空间里面去打开新局面的事。
我觉得这个您说的很好。
就是除了整个社会上。
你做企业
你需要创新往新的政产列来发展。
你作为一个公务员。
就是政府的工作者。
你也得有这种创新的思想和执行力。
但是谁敢这么干呢？
我就是我要是以普通的基层公务员。
我也不敢
你说的也是大实话。
你如果先进入公务员体系。
首先你先好好地贯彻领导的具体之力。
当然慢慢成长起来以后。
他可能就有一些自己的这种发挥作用的空间。
80年代中期有一个当时称为的。
中青年的活跃时期。
那时候就是开始打破这种沉闷局面。
高层也是给予肯定的。
莫盖山会议现在大家实施谈起。
就说到当时那种新的精神状态。
一种新的潮流
当然以后慢慢又恢复到了。
这些中青年也成长起来了。
确实有一些人走上领导岗位了。
有些人也是经商去了。
少数像我这样一直坚持这个科研的不多。
对呀 您这最不挣钱了。
这么多年下来
我当然我做科研
我有自己的自得其乐之处。
我称为情节之所在。
但总体的社会来说。
还是要鼓励一线做实事的人。
协议界的人
公务员方面
有一定的创新精神。
把事情做到建设性的人。
应该得到鼓励
那么科研的人
他在后面更多的是提供一些参考。
提供一些治理支持的成果。
起到点咨询和参考配合作用。
我觉得您刚刚说的。
整个改革的方案和图景。
以及对基层人员的期望都很好。
因为前几种展望都很好。
您听说我怎么样来解决我自己。
首先家长绝度过得去。
是吧 我能考出一个好学校。
学校毕业
我能找到一下下的工作。
如果找不到 会偷偷脸 非常痛苦。
他很难得想我什么？
贴下新王皮肤有错。
而且您说的那每一个。
需要他们创新的个人。
他也都面临现在现实生活的这些问题。
对 承认这种现实生活的制约。
他在不处理这些问题。
没有处理好的时候。
他怎么敢去在工作上。
大胆创新或改革
待会把我这个饭碗创飞了。
对 他越来越多的。
现在是前理学教授所说的。
精致的立即主义者。
他好不容易进了公园体系。
那是前面 高桃态率。
考试 面试 然后呆了。
来了以后他越来越多的感觉。
谁会差远观色
谁会投领导所
更有用
谁就可能有发展前途。
自然而然大家都学。
都走这条道
那就竞争谁能更得到领导欢兴。
那么真正的创新 真正创造性。
他就不考虑了
对 创新的人一般都是招人烦的。
那就是这个问题
我们得承认社会的复杂性。
事务的复杂性 确实是这样。
对 那回到说刚才您说的。
就是有一个长期的改革的途径。
然后我们也有那个短期的。
财政政策 货币政策的这位激励。
对 通盘的考虑
到底怎么样解决中国经济社会专轨。
中国历史三峡这个问题。
那咱们这个短期的。
财政政策 货币政策。
我们到底什么时候能看到一个成效。
能在体感上觉得说。
我们的经济好起来了。
应该讲 如果没有这样的政策。
现在经济状况一定要更糟糕。
你看 在2022年的时候。
有一个防疫的转断 那其实是很重要的。
2022年11月 中央指导之下。
威建委明确地说
新冠疫情到了奥米克隆阶段。
降格为以类传染病。
不再跟它清零严防厮守。
那么放开社会
经过两个月左右的时间。
各地持或造
但总体来说就是两个月。
就扛过了高压力气。
到了2023年的春季长假期间。
有人冷无丁网上说了一句。
怎么没人讲奥米克隆了 就是扛过来了。
扛过来了 这有可能打开新局面。
那时候整个社会上的预期都不好。
我看到所有的
有这种影响力的预测主体。
国外的 包括国内的一些。
他们必须对客户报告的眷商。
他们要出现就报告。
没有一家看到说
2023年我们的增长能达到5%的。
但是中央明确地提出。
2023年银导性的5%到15%。
那么执行过程中间。
曾经有压力的这种明显表现。
破天荒的到了第四季度。
启动预算调整方案。
发行特别过窄
那么靠这个政策的作用。
就把那一年实际达到了5.2%。
你如果没有
我说的快别量的这种政策。
那就不可能有这个结果。
2024年仍然是没有人预测能达到5%。
我们继续提银导性的5%。
而且又达到了
延续到去年2025年。
也是经过努力
还是5%
这就出现了延续三年5%。
或者5%稍高一点。
这就是说明在中高速。
这个实际上的比较下眼的位置上。
我们已经出现了一个。
由心入肠的可能性的这样一个小平台。
今年提4.5到5。
给了更大的应对不确定性的那种弹性。
但同时呢？
说工作中还可以经过努力争取更好的结果。
实际上就是4.5到5还可以5出头。
仍然是要努力达到半支5左右。
我有一句话不知道当不当问。
就是这数字我们能信吗？
那我要反问一句
你不信这个你信谁。
也是
有一些人是在抨击说我们的数字。
可能有水分
但统计局一直说
我们并不是靠地方政府报上联书。
合在一起形成的数据。
统计局说我们有办法。
通过集水分的方式。
不是主要依据地方报的数据。
我们得到总体的宏观数据。
你如果不信这个数据。
那就找不到讨论问题的这种数据参照系。
就只能自己做社会调研了。
你说的调研你达不出选位的结果。
说水分多少
各种说法都有
你信哪一家的
那我理解
您的意思就是说
我们现在财政政策。
货币政策做的所有努力。
只是说让我们不会更差。
对
要配合全局
不会更差
而且争取向好
但你光靠宏观政策这个发力。
已经到双松状态了。
超长规的
这是中央文件里说的字样了。
但你没有真正改革这方面的。
万变量跟上的话
我说就要快变量和万变量的接力与合力。
这是要继续下功夫的。
那未来也只能是说。
在这个避免更差的路上走下去了吗？
不能说只能这样
我们争取就是避免更差。
而同时争取更好
就是我们怎么就开始走向了。
这样一个尽量避免更差的道路。
那就简单再回顾一下。
说得稍远一点
中国改革开放前面非常重要的一个关节点。
就是1992年邓小平南方谈话。
仅跟着确立市场经济目标模式。
这样一来在跟着后面。
我们正确处理了和外部世界的关系。
千年之交前后
美国签字同意中国入市。
我们更好地拥抱了全球化。
然后千年之交之后出现了一个。
我们在2023年战胜非典之后。
当年就站在了10%两位数增长的新界的。
迅速出现一个发展高潮。
黄金时期
那么这种中国经济经历了。
改革开放的各个阶段以后。
走到了一个起飞状态。
在走到2010年的时候成功抵离了世纪金融危机的时候。
我们当年又站在了两位数上。
10.6是明显的高速度。
据说算总让
改革开放开始到这时候30年。
年金增速9.8%。
四捨五如就是10%。
两位数的
而从小平南方谈话到2010年。
年金增长速度超过10%。
这个黄金发展的时期。
打了一个很好的底子。
但是它粗放特征也非常明显。
2010年的时候。
中央在经济工作会上明确提出了。
稳中求尽指导方针。
那么合合逻辑的认识就中央意识到了。
黄金发展期特征
虽然还在矛盾凸显期的特征来了。
要稳住阵脚化解
威胁我们行稳志愿的不利因素。
那么就必须认识适应和引领新常态。
这就是一个在中央指导之下。
主观因素和客观因素结合在一起。
开始下行的一个拐点。
我们以后不可能再出现。
2010年的高速两位数增长局面。
那么那是最后我们的经济起飞。
高速发展阶段的回光返照。
以后在2010年以后。
贯彻中央这个方针。
两年时间速度就落到了8%以下。
再有三年时间相对缓慢的落到了7%以下。
那当然仍然是中高速。
这时候要追求什么？
追求客户结构矛盾。
作为矛盾主要方面制约的速度。
缓解往下降
但质量怎么提升
要解决这个问题
解决高质量发展问题。
中央明确的就给出了战略方针。
叫做供给侧结构性改革。
供给侧的制度重新带出。
整个供给体系质量和效率的提高。
这个直到方针从认识适应。
引领新常态一直落到了供给侧改革。
再以后中央说
这是我们实现新的两步走线的话的主线。
也就是几十年之间。
这条线是不能断的。
这就落到我说的改革是质本。
是解放生产力的它的关键意中。
是中央现在说的
整个时代列车的迁引力火车头。
那么再往后呢？
怎么贯彻这供给侧改革。
七六点叫三去一降一五。
可能现在很多人还有印象。
对 有印象
优化结构怎么样改变原来的。
有效供给不足
那么有了这样一个贯彻过程中间。
三年我们的六点七到六点九。
很载基金的波动一直走到了18年。
这时候当时觉得很有希望来确认。
这个由新入场所谓L型转换是个比喻。
速度下调以后
尾巴拉出来以后进入平台转。
六点七到六就很好啊？
这个速度是美国最满意速度的两倍以上。
是欧洲日本他们满意的速度三到四倍。
我们可以在这个高占发展的同时。
仍然不断缩小跟这个发达经济的差距。
但是不期而遇的
2018年一季度以后。
美中关系发现发生重大变化。
就是美国朝野空前一日到了一个新的状态。
要全面遏制中国
这其实就是从丛林法则起作用。
不论人类文明说了多少自由平等不爱。
到了老大觉得老二挑战他的头号地位的时候。
就是要把它按住两党吵得一塌糊涂。
但是谁对中国是想谁去加分。
老百姓所谓选民也都认同。
我们就要把中国押入到了这么一个邻界点。
所以基金额很快就说。
中美关系回不到从前了。
还要警惕滑入内冷战。
滑入不良的冷战状态。
这就是我们一个调试的过程。
贸易战和止贸易很快的。
科技战外交战金融战。
感受都来了
再有就是是不是还会有擦枪走火的热战风险。
这样一来我们这个速度跟着预期不好往下落。
落到了2010年只有6.1了。
跟着又是三年疫情。
又出现了就是速度进一步的下行。
当然原因就比较复杂了。
前面已经累计的阶段转换。
美中关系交恶还都在影响。
疫情本身的冲击
那带来整个经济社会的严重的拖累。
再加上2021年连理经济工作会议精神传达手。
中裁办负责常务预刑工作的韩文修复人。
严谨已该职业部会点到的。
我们主观上必须揪片的双重谬误。
合在一起这个疫情以后。
2020、2021年两年的复合平均资料速度。
已经从原来的6左右落到5.1。
再往后2022、2023年两年的复合平均资料速度。
只有4.1多一点。
那明显划出了我们实现新的两步走。
这个整个的现代化战略安排。
所要求的保证速度。
所以中央有这样的标出。
把经济已经维护在合理区间。
那么2023年确实契机之年。
跟前面合在一起的复合平均资料速度。
就能够把曲线修匀以后。
是已经跌到了合理区间的下沿以下。
但它当年同比毕竟站在了无以上。
这样的一个状态
就是我们现在成千起合要看清楚的。
面对十四五以后的十五开局。
中央说我们是实现新的两步走第一步。
2035基本建设是有主意现代化的。
要夯实基础全面发力的关键性时期。
这话就不是空话了。
所以从目前来看
就是这一路走来到现在。
其实我们整体的政策的方向是对的。
没有什么大的问题。
但是不是一直都是说。
经济学家他就是其实是可以预测一些。
经济的发展走势吗？
那您说怎么没提前十年预测到。
到这会快不行了
然后就提前改革一下子呢？
经济学家有预测
但是现在人们已经讲了。
比如有的乐观的讲。
中国还可以有20年的18%左右的增长。
一般认为那就是说的太乐观了。
有些人认为就应该跌倒五一下。
四也没关系
三也没关系
老百姓得失惠制性。
这话说的就有点轻飘飘。
因为你得考虑中央整个的战略部署。
中央整个办理部署在十四五的时候。
是给出了一个15年的从来没有过的。
远景目标规划
写作组经过认真研究测算。
认为我们很有希望。
2035年的时候。
中国的新纪总量或折围人均的GDP。
比2020年全面押韩之年。
再翻一翻
学者这时候做测算。
完全可以形成一个量值的认识。
就是人口14.3亿鉴定。
又逐渐在下调
要看我们的鼓励生意的政策发力。
结果如何
那可以设人口的高中低。
三种假设情境
测算下来15年
年均的增长速度要达到。
领导人所说的那个目标。
必须是在4.5到4.9这个局限。
中位数就是4.7。
而且你得准备这15年间。
经济基础抬高以后。
最大可能性的
就是速度中心要下调。
所以要争取15年的前半段。
我们要在无以上为好。
过了这前半段往下调。
也不要调得太深
这样的一个说法
就是整个15年算总。
让年均增长速度激进5。
是不是我们一厢情愿。
这种问题的时日
大量的学者是有测算的。
落到一个所谓潜在经济增长率。
这个认识上
要我说所谓潜在经济增长率就是。
这个经济体
它自己在运行中间既没有明显通胀。
也没有明显通缩
这时候它应该表现出来的那个速度水平。
这跟它的成长性有关。
当然也跟它的主观方面。
政策掌握不出大的差数有关。
这个潜在经济增长速度增长率。
所有的预测结果都认为不低于5%。
所以这就是说
从可能的经济学者做的预测来说。
它还是支持领导人所说的这个前景。
当然所有的经济学家都得承认。
这么多年搞数量化的模型 数据库。
但是谁也不敢夸口。
能准确预测下一个短期的经济的。
精确数据
我前面说了这几年。
所有的预测主题都不看好中国经济。
都说是要跌到5%以下。
但我们仍然提5%。
那么长期呢？
却相对来说更容易啊？
八九不离十
你说是不是因为5%是大家的一个心理价位。
统计学家们让它尽量不要低于5%。
那可能主观上来我不能做这个评价。
我有这么个说法
就是中央在文件里从来没有讲过。
中高速的量值去见是多少。
我自己觉得我做了这么多年的红冠经济。
但是我特长不是在建国。
但我毕竟有这种感觉的东西。
综合起来的一个直觉上的东西。
我觉得中国的中高速啊？
大概可以看在5到8的区间。
8以上就接近高速了。
5再往下走
可能就冲上中高速。
开始中低速
再往下就是低速了。
这个5或者5左右。
完全使中国可以继续推进它的现代化战略。
就是追赶 赶超发达经济体。
因为美国最满意的速度2.5。
2.5在网上接近3。
它的美联储一定要控制通胀。
这是种种因素造成。
它就是这个速度水平。
欧洲和日本这些年能达到1.5就相当满意。
所以我们这个5或者5左右的速度。
既有前面测算了这样一套。
关联于新的两步走战略的这种直观的联系。
也有我们自己认为。
中国的客观成长性加上主观能力。
主观努力当然也很关键。
去实现潜在经济增长率。
变为现实增长率
1.5%左右这么一个过程。
不是简单的印象情愿。
就是说我们目前希望。
是我们到2035年的平均增速在1.5%左右。
或者接近1.5%。
但是即使是低于5。
比如说4.2%
其实也是属于一个正常的。
比发达经济体其实高很多的状态。
如果说是波动的话。
有那么一段时间低于1.5%。
也可能过一段时间稍微高一点1.5%。
这个可能性不排除。
但是大概率这样看来它还是一个平稳的。
就是总体来说
我认为中国的客观的成长性。
就是我们的工业化和成正化。
还有相当可观的纵深和空间。
就是客观的支撑因素。
主观努力当然就是。
在工业化 成正化推进的旁边。
我们要坚定不易的市场化。
国际化和信息化
再加上法治民主化。
客观主观合在一起。
大概率这960万平方公里。
未来的场景做个勾化。
就是3000个出头的行政区化。
是线区以上一直属到北上广深一线城市。
这3000个出头里面。
大概有700个左右。
不到四分之一 接近四分之一。
可以认定为明显的增长机区域。
这些增长机区域它是发挥主导作用的。
它在未来新的两步走过程中间。
一定是表现为城乡结合部外推。
北京还能再推吗？
北京是没办法了
推到五环以后人家推到五环。
所以有一个北京的特殊处理。
控制人口 这是没办法的。
北京是特殊的首都情况。
要单独讨论
那别的一些我说的这700个左右。
大多数你是客观规律上必须适应着。
它的呈现结合部外推。
干嘛呢？
要准备接纳
未来还有几亿中国人要从东村。
迁徙到城市
他们主要要涌入这些中心区域。
增长机区域
还要给已经在这些区域里的。
将近3亿农民攻击机架数5000帐。
改善他们的居住 教育 养老 医疗条件。
所以要一轮一轮的。
技术实施建设和技术实施生计环带。
现在要城市更新
要建好房子 给老百姓得更多的实惠。
要推进基本公共服务军等化。
这样的一个过程伴随的是什么？
中国一轮一轮的产业互动 产业升级。
到现在到了AI加带领的。
数式融合推进的高质量。
培育新制生产力的发展。
还有一轮一轮的人力资本的培育。
咱们前面已经讨论的。
到底怎么样培养这些不同层次的创新型人才。
合在一起这个可能性存在着。
我们要努力把它变成现实。
这个可能性变成现实。
只要我们自己不犯特别明显的经济错误。
我觉得它是大概率。
所以从这个大概率的时候。
我们如果不是只限于。
现在关于不愉快的 困难的。
甚至要躺平的这些感受。
而是看到中国它的成长性。
客观之称加上主观努力的我们的前景。
在世界方面来看
中国一定是一个特大规模经济体。
释放出天亮的需求。
而得到双循环带来的本土确定性。
而外面也要努力争取的。
各种有效攻击的回应。
这就是一个特大规模经济体。
继续完成它的成长过程的。
这么一个现实的前景。
那你如果作为一个。
自己安身立命的个体。
作为一个创业上心的企业主体。
最大的这种机遇出现的大场景。
你一定不能放过
那不就是AI吗？
中国包括AI
包括AI现在从一到一百。
已经感觉很有亮点。
当然还要继续努力。
从零到一的突破我们继续观察。
还有没有可能出现一些什么弯道超车。
比如说芯片到了两纳米。
已经到极限了
模尔定律到头了
现在说有可能新的技术路线。
到底如何
淘定律吗 不是
是的
你这个信息很全
它这个突破现在还不敢确认。
但是看到了一些端倪。
我们一定要努力
这样一来整个的如果说。
作为一个个人的安身立命。
实现自己人生价值。
一定不能简单地说。
我就不看中国
而且很多人实在是在。
首选要继续看中国这方面。
可能给它的机遇
这种机遇往往有胆是有魄力的人。
它是眼光独到的
贸易战打响以后 剑拔弩张。
大家人心晃晃的时候。
这个MASK被称为男神式的这个。
现在大家知道世界首富。
它突然启动到上海跟上海市场签约。
建全球最大规模的外商投资单体工厂。
对 那个时候还挺出奇不易的。
这就是贯彻了巴菲特所说的。
众人恐惧的时候我可以贪婪。
那人家有资本贪婪。
有他的自己的意见性。
你得承认这个看法他是很。
很有他的这种底气的。
他看到了别人没有看到的机遇。
谈一个好的对价 该出手的就出手。
结果他这个上海的最大规模单体工厂后来披露。
一个厂投资当量大概是500亿人民币以上。
一年出头的时间
生产线就远远开动。
生产高质上的次次拉新能源汽车。
这个新能源汽车它还特别的。
它是开源的
它把它所有的这个专利什么的。
不保留的公开出来。
你们愿意抄就抄吧？
它就有这个底气
这个举措成为它在新能源汽车赛道上。
扭亏为营的转折点。
在此之前都是那个风险投资。
看好它的前景在它的亏损情况下。
给它支持
而到了特斯拉在上海成功以后。
这个模式使它不断的赚钱。
而且它现在把这个模式复制到墨西哥和欧洲。
这就变成出什么呢？
投资便利化 贸易自由化的陪伴之下。
仍然是人类文明发展的主潮流。
反正未来我们大概率不会更差了。
不敢说短期波动中间没有更差的感觉。
你得看什么赛道什么领域。
但是比如说到2035年这个区间。
像您描绘的
我们要争取越来越多的人感觉到回暖。
温差要减少
就在这个回暖的过程中。
也许还会有一些时代机遇。
有机遇 我觉得得承认有机遇。
我感觉到就企业家里面。
有一些人他们是很执着的。
他们称为长期主义。
这个长期主义有道理。
我前面说到的中国的客观的生长性。
加上主观方面
八九不离十 贯彻这个大政方针。
那么就值得我们不受一些不愉快。
一些阶段性的
甚至有些时候闹得人心慌慌的。
比如远洋捕捞这种不良的情况的干扰。
坚持在自己的赛道上坐下去。
当然他也得有一些自己的生存智慧。
你总得先活下来
企业家碰到一些困难说。
首先说要活下来
万客能不能真的活下来。
咱们还得拭目以待。
几年前郁将就说这个话了。
他有预感
但是你只要能活下来继续努力。
可能很多的机遇还是会跟着来的。
听起来您其实挺欣赏马斯克的 是吧？
我觉得你得承认
他这里边有些东西我们现在还看不懂。
但是他已经做的一些东西非常值得肯定。
他那种在航天方面。
能够把官方比拼下去的实际的成果。
非常雄变
但是有他的偶然性。
他山雄水晶那时候最后一次实现成功了。
他那个火箭发动机。
马上就要破产了
马上破产
最后一次机会 成功了。
但是这是他的偶然性。
他的必然性是什么呢？
只有美国这样的特别的宽容。
允许这种被人们认为。
带着疯狂特征的创业者去试措。
最后他终于现在成了航天方面。
稳定的有这种欲在火箭主体。
回收能力的主体
他就可以对接他的火星一臂计划。
在美国他冒出头来了。
他现在的脑机接口到底怎么样。
可能是解前沿
当然又带来一个危险。
咱们也是这么说
我觉得得讨论
他自己也说
如果走到一个基点上。
脑机接口就不是解决这个残疾人。
怎么恢复功能的问题。
他可能制造出了少数的超人。
特别聪明 特别有胆识魄力的人。
加上计算机的负能。
这种超人他按人的本性来说。
他有可能发展到不受制约的。
奴役其他的人类
那整个人类文明成果就变成负面了。
这叫基点 人工智能继续发展出来。
科技创新 怎么避免这个前景。
技术能力离那已经不远了。
西方一些客观点已经讲这个危险。
这个还得拭目以待。
总体来说我们得承认。
马斯克这样人对人类的发展。
是有他独特贡献的。
他一定会犯错误
他有些东西不确定性我们看不懂。
也不要简单先否定他。
所以这又回到那个主题。
就是中国什么时候能有。
马斯克和SpaceX这样的前纪。
这是前纪森之问 理约社之谜。
在中国 大家已经探讨多年。
蒋浅康老师
我们最近6月21号马斯克发了一条推特。
聊到了说最好直接把钱。
从财政部发给民众。
只要商品和服务增长。
超过了货币供应增长。
而有了人工智能和机器人。
这一点将得以实现。
就不会有通货膨胀。
他说我们的预测是。
我们将拼命对抗通货紧缩。
请您给我们解读一下。
他这个说法其实不新鲜。
就是在建议直升飞机撒钱式的。
给老百姓按人头发钱这方面。
早就有很多人都说。
对 咱国内也要建议啊 说吧？
在实践上也有
比如说咱们华人社会为主的。
新加坡回归祖国的台湾。
也包括香港 澳门都有过。
这种做法一旦出手。
肯定老百姓鼓掌
人人都得到一份
对啊？
美国在前面应对谁进入危机。
但是它自己惹的货。
金融创新走过了头。
金融海啸升级为金融危机以后。
它搞量化宽松
也盛传说美国是人人都发钱。
后来我查了一下不是这样。
美国是把一定收水平以上的人。
画出来
大概它的社会成员里边一半。
或者一半稍微多一点。
这些人可以拿到至少两轮发过。
那量级是多少呢？
每个人有2000到3000发一次。
给挣得多的发
就是达到它画的线的这一边的人。
就是相对收入低的这一边人。
低的那一边
相对低的这边人都发。
当然就不会很精确吧？
但它敢这么干
敢这么干也没听说。
美国老百姓说
我这线比你稍微高一点。
我跟政府没有了
你算得不准
你得给我发
它也比较简单
不像咱们原则上说的低保。
低保你低到什么程度。
我怎么给你补多少。
还得算一算
有地方质量也算不清楚。
美国它这么做
它社会也接受
对 咱不能这么干吗？
中国在具体来讲
一个是什么呢？
我们的人口基础太大。
发不起
你算发多少
如果一个人发3000块钱。
是相当于多少呢？
400美元出头
不到500美元
你如果在地上有点不好意思出手了吧？
一个人发3000人民币。
400美元出头的这个东西。
那整个中国得多少。
4万多亿
这比那时候政府一览子刺激发。
4万亿都还要高
政府面对这么多的事情。
压力是非常明显的。
已经地方政府普遍困难。
中央政府也是赤字率不断提升。
负债大家都感觉有压力。
这时候只能以负债的方式。
拿这笔钱了
再做这个事情
决心是不是下得来。
这只是一个因素
更关键的什么？
就是中国特别强调。
社会的可接受性
就是道理上要说得好。
有什么必要
你给马云也发一笔钱。
有什么必要给富裕的。
这些跑到环球景城。
去灰金如土的人也发一笔钱。
蒋浩老师
我上个月刚取了环球影响。
你肯定也中高层吧？
不至于灰金如土
但是有这么形容
没有区别就没有政策。
我搞区别了
搞区别的中国会出现这个问题。
你看什么样的划线。
你说家庭收入不行。
家庭有的人是定个家庭两个人。
有的家庭是五个人。
那就得按人群收入。
人群收入算得准算不准。
另外你算出来以后。
可能很多人跟政府故意不绕。
你没有考虑到我还有一个养女。
我还有个养妇
这哪纠缠得过来呢？
是吧？
这就很难操作
管理成本会非常高。
在中国这个事情
有这么多轮的议论呢？
一个是总量上的压力。
一个是政策上老百姓认可。
没有受到很多的够病的。
这种经历设计的这个必要性。
合在一起
那么这个决心怎么下就比较难了。
在实际生活中间
取而代之的一些建议我提过。
如果说在这方面
体现更多的策证于低中收入阶层。
也同时推进了
共同富裕又调动了消费潜力。
又改善了低端社会成员的。
他的境域
那么是不也借鉴美国早就有的。
那种配给卷的办法。
我在美国作为一年访问学者。
我是目睹了这个情况。
比如说在那超市门口。
有黑人母亲带着几个孩子。
推着满满两车东西出来了。
在结账的地方
他拿出一大杂字那个配给卷。
政府认定他的低收入以后。
就按照他带的孩子什么东西的信息。
就给他发这个卷
这个建的政府指定的这种超市。
可以买生活用品
鸡蛋 面包 牛奶 肉肠都来了。
慢慢两个推车出来了回家去。
那么改善了他们的境域。
也不产生其他什么更麻烦的管理问题。
他拿到的不是现金有什么好处。
他只能消费买
他只能是满足基本生活需要。
他不会拿去喝酒不会拿去赌博。
咱们不是也有消费卷。
但是还是不太一样。
我们的消费卷就另外一回事。
我们消费卷主要是政府和厂家联合促销。
对应的是低收入阶层上边的那种。
有积极性的低中收入和年轻白领。
对 他其实不是针对。
底层人民的生活保障。
不是真的最底层
最底层的他自己轻易不敢下管子。
你拿这个消费卷给他起不了太大作用。
现在我们还有已就换新政策。
对 已就换新
真正的低收入阶层他也很难考虑。
他怎么已就换新
不用说没有
但他不是主力
对 已就换新也都是电子产品。
电器 汽车这些
加用难用品也有一些消费信贷。
真正的低收入阶层他特别的小心翼翼。
他轻易也不去借贷。
也起不了特别大的作用。
那我们为什么没有采用这个方法。
是不是这些人群也不太好统计。
对 我再接着说
这个可以消除我说的。
支撑飞机撒钱的那样的种种的。
难以下决心的这种顾虑 是吧？
也更多体现了差别。
这个政策设计听了也有道理。
但也担心什么呢？
你在中国做这个事情。
会出现一个倒卖票证的黄牛市场。
那肯定会的 我听起来就像个生意。
中国的特点就是这样。
过去有良票的时候。
就曾经拿良票在市场去换鸡蛋。
我都干过这个事 对吧？
那就是一个黄牛市场。
以后良票取消了
实名制 这个票得实名制。
这个票实名制拿身份证去取消费。
对 跟那演唱会的门票似的。
你说这个建议倒也可以。
都是管理上来说
成本也不低
当然会不会催生一个伪造身份证市场。
这也难说
这些事情 当然你如果从电子信息来说。
它伪造的过不了关 是吧？
技术能够把握
现在支付宝东都刷脸了。
我感觉这个应该没什么技术难度。
你说这个建议
我觉得可以提交给有关部门。
哎呀 倒是说记得给我鼠名。
对 但有人说中国扫脸已经太多了。
个人的生物信息的隐私。
在中国最不受保护什么的。
现在过不了隐私了。
咱先过着活着的事。
现在你说做高铁就是靠生物证。
很多的场合就是靠扫脸。
但是现在旅店说可以不扫脸了。
这是对外国游客的让步。
人家不接受 你就必须再退下来。
包括之前那个消费券。
其实有人诟病说
其实是商家变相长假了。
然后再让你用消费券。
有这种可能性
因为它本来是可以打折到那个转转。
本来是商家跟政府联合塑销。
大家印象上是有好处的。
但是很多的人并不知道原来的价位是多少。
现在你说这个价位是多少。
我拿这个券马上就可以优惠多少。
它只看这一段了
是的
反正这件事情在提振消费这方面。
怎么样理性设计可以讨论。
但总体来说它不是根本性的。
您说下马斯克说的这个。
只要商品和服务增长。
超过货币功能增长。
然后有了AI之后就不会有通货膨胀了。
这个是怎么理解的。
他是说的这么一个循环。
就是越来越多的靠机器人生产出来的东西。
那么带来的东西是有效攻击的话。
老百姓拿到政府给的这个钱。
给我买了一区
形成自己的最终消费。
对经济无憾
它实际上带来的什么一个可能性呢？
我觉得说破了就是越来越多的机器人。
使我们原来的就业岗为减少。
那么实际上带来的是社会成员咸狭的提供。
你如果掌握得好
无非就是每周六小时工作。
早已经变成六天工作。
变成五天工作
那么我们可以进一步。
把它缩小为每周四天工作。
三天工作
对 人家欧洲有的国家已经四天了。
已经在审
咱凭个时候
每周工作是八小时。
你可以缩小为六小时 五小时。
以后半天 四小时。
这是什么 老百姓得市会呀？
老百姓的闲下时间多了。
你只要这个东西
它进入一个它所说的机器人AI。
能够把有效供给永远不断提供出来。
那么社会就无憾
老百姓就更多的去享受自己的旅游。
享受自己海滩晒太阳。
享受自己去打灌弹。
这合乐而不为呢？
对 它之前就是说机器人以后能取代很多工作。
然后我们以后大部分人都不需要工作。
但它说的这个促进的这个手段。
就是靠政府直升飞机撒钱。
这个局限性是有的。
就是我们分析的
不是说哪个经济拿着就能用的。
它说这话是为了促进它那个AI这个事吗？
我觉得它不管有意无异。
它是想得到一片喝彩生。
老百姓听了当然高兴。
好 对我们刚才说的消费券。
那您觉得比起来
发现金或者消费券。
还有就是减税或者社保补贴的。
哪一个方法其实更有效应。
就是组合考虑
在这个减税上有空间的话。
当然要积极运用
咱们国家曾经反复强劣过减税降户。
但这几年不那么强调。
为什么呢？
就是那空间用的差不多了。
当然方向是还要继续减税。
但是就没有前几年那样的力度了。
那么这时候更多的叫做以转移支付。
给低数阶层托底这个事就更重要了。
咱们的低保应该做到应保尽保。
这原则上怎么说
管理上怎么更过系。
那就得考验各个地方的这个具体工作的水平了。
我们不否定存在有骗保的情况。
很难避免 是吧？
你在这方面过去
凡是有补贴的地方都有这骗补的情况发生。
不要它大量发生
总体来说让这个政策能够主流上提现。
它应该有的
给低数阶层托好底这个作用。
低数阶层托好底
那么在网上低中数阶层呢？
它这方面更多的要在激励这方面呢？
也要想注意在就业的培训呢？
这个政府支持的灵活就业啊？
在网上呢？
有消费这方面场景偏好的这些人。
比如年轻白领 新生代。
他们愿意下管子
愿意到外面去参加集体的那种这个。
奖励华社的消费活动。
这时候有政府和商家联合的促销消费券。
这些措施之外
但是还有咱已经有的。
移旧换新调动这个潜力啊？
移旧换系里摆一些绿色低碳的耐有消费品。
更多的推向实际使用过程中间。
配合了国家的双探战略等等。
就是综合考虑
但原头上我特别强调。
就不能光讲消费
消费它最根本的支撑力是什么？
是消费能力
消费能力是收入
对
收入怎么来呢？
要靠就业岗位
就业岗位是稳定的。
大宗的 可预期的老百姓。
自己心里踏实了
这个消费能力的行程来源。
那就要问就业岗位怎么样实现。
有效投资
所以就从消费要扯到上面的。
有效投资 提高投资效益。
这个投资跟就业岗位的关联是怎么？
投资是提供就业岗位的。
它的最主要的切入点。
你说政府投资是吧？
不 有些投资分类。
政府的业下投资和企业的业下投资。
如果经济运行的比较好。
政府不用特别发力的情况下。
就是企业自己创业创新。
远远不断提供出就业岗位。
那当然是最好的状态。
但现在不行了
现在我们企业的投资。
特别中国民营企业投资这些年。
它明显是低迷的
政府投资这时候就非常有意义了。
要政府两重投资
政府这时候发力
做那种平时心有余而力不足。
要做的国家重大的安全条件。
所要求的基础设施。
战略性安排的基础设施。
那比如说减灾房灾。
比如说特大工程
比如说在这个中心区域。
早就说了多年的要把海绵城市。
海绵流域要跟着这个中心区域。
呈骗的一块设计
跟着的更广泛的外面的。
基本冬天灌溉体系。
通坛考虑起来
这是一个良众
显然要考虑的
要做的事
而你一旦到中心区域。
要做这个海绵城市的建设。
在地底下打主意的这些事。
要涉及到地下综合港栏和地铁。
轨道交通网建设
又是迫切需要解决的问题。
而这个地下交通网轨道建设。
在一些中心城市
现在的国际性太明显了。
比如北京上海这么多年来。
在努力发展轨道交通。
仍然赶不上社会需要。
赶不上的标志是什么？
你不敢让老百姓讲买车就买车。
北京已经搞了这么多年的限购。
现在还要以限号的方式来现行。
上海一开始经济手段为主。
来卖它最贵的铁皮。
后来听说是要加上行政手段。
北京不敢搞经济手段。
跟上海的情况有明显区别。
就完全靠摇号
负责用太明显了
我已经排十年了
这个负责用带来的直观的看。
催生出一个非常复杂的。
所谓倒卖车牌的黑市。
那个复杂程序说
怎么结婚离婚
几道导手
最终把车牌弄到需要的人手上。
这是非常荒唐的
这是国际笑话式的一个荒唐状态。
但它就届实存在着的。
那么我查了纽约 东京。
机动车应用率都比北京高。
但人家完全不用做这种限考课。
限行
当然它有特殊情况。
提出什么拥堵费什么的。
经济手段 局务实施。
它依靠的就是
它的轨道交通网
四通八达 密度基本 到位。
老百姓愿意买车就买车。
买车主要是做什么呢？
应急和到了周末
往外开去享受生活。
假日出去兜风 旅游。
这就病情不备了
它的基础是
公共基础硕士的支撑力。
达到了这样一种
总体来说
大家都过得去的状态。
不是说没有摩擦
没有矛盾
但绝对不像北京 上海这样。
要严厉的来献购献幸。
献购献幸逼着大家什么的。
很多家庭的车子拿来。
干嘛接送孩子
逼着他还要千方百计。
去买第二辆车
很多的东西适得其反。
造成了更多的一些负作用。
您的意思是
应该国家投资地下交通网络。
对 随我前面说了。
政府的两重这时候。
能够解决政府该做的这些事情。
从减在房灾的海滨城市。
一直扯到地下总统管理。
它是整个在物理空间。
国土开发上面
应该成功配套的
是此其十亿
赶快利用我们的特别国债。
地方专项债
还有超长期的国债。
把这些事情做得有色有色。
做这种政府有条投资带来的什么呢？
马上产生一大批就业。
产生一大批订单
刚才水泥设备
原来所谓的过程产能瞬间。
就被它转为有效产能。
这不是提升经济景气。
也能促进买车的消费。
对 跟着就促进了老百姓。
跟着就业 跟着景气上升来说的。
收入和改于消费的这个环境。
那为什么不赶紧弄呢？
现在正在做
现在国家提出六网。
什么电网 水网 路网。
这都是两种涉及到建设的事。
但这只是政府做的有效投资。
还要积极地让企业有效投资跟进。
现在鼓励企业 包括民企业。
参与国家基础设施建设。
那么也是增加可用的社会资金量。
提供更多的就业方位。
咱们国家不是一直都被说为基建狂魔。
就是说我们的基建水平。
其实明显在提高
对 已经很多时候都比周都发达国家。
还要厉害了
比如说这些地铁什么？
它们很老旧了
那我们还真的有这么大的空间。
需要再去搞基建吗？
有 非常必要
像北京这个地铁起了个大早。
改了个晚级
现在的努力建设吧？
但是还是赶不上社会需要的增长。
所以它现在还得严格的。
来对基金车做这些限制。
什么时候跟你为东京一样。
你放开想买车就买车。
那就对头了
所以其实并不是为了增加收入。
硬去搞
而且说我们真的有这个必要。
然后顺便它也能提高收入。
类似这样的地方在中国。
几十个特大型和大型城市叫赶快建。
赶快做合理的轨道交通网的建设方案。
越做得早
以后在历史上算总让越核算。
而且现在正是需要扩大内需的时候。
要趁这个扩大内需的东风。
所以其实现在如果想要增强大家的安全感。
我觉得现在其实主要是。
安全感的收入的安全感的问题。
一个是提到收入
一个是不是就是稳房价。
就是这两件事如果稳定了。
大家的信心就增强了。
是的
你看现在房价市场气稳。
其实已经入了端倪。
还要继续把这个事处理好。
在提供更多就业岗位。
提供更多的市场订单这方面。
我们大有可为
我是觉得现在有一些认识。
明显陷入误区的
比如说中国的投资已经饱和。
地方政府找不到合适投资项目了。
这完全不对应于现实。
但是现在就是感觉说。
地方政府和国家的钱都不富裕。
他们还能这样搞有效投资吗？
所以地方专项债 特别国债。
超长期特别国债
是主要的筹字工具。
再加上PPP 瑞士等等这种。
调动社会资本跟进的机制。
合在一起我们完全可以做。
从经济角度来说完全可以这么做。
社会和政治角度就得做什么呢？
法治化
你要有全民一法治国的实实在在的进步。
才能让老百姓感觉这么做公债发出来。
是可以配上稳定的政治环境的。
配上以后越来越可能的。
保护产权公平经营争上。
企业特别明显敢于介入。
这种大规模建设领域的社会条件。
就高标准法治化营商环境。
所以这种事情也倒逼我们。
从经济层面上升到社会层面。
和政治层面的进步。
那您说的不管是说。
国家层面的还是企业层面的。
提升居民的收入
和这种安全感
其实从我们个人角度来说。
这是一个被动的
就是等着大家去干这件事。
但是从我们个人角度来说。
我们怎么能主动的。
我们可以省市夺市看着。
那特别是企业界的人士。
有些企业
它的偏好就是
我愿意跟政府合作来做点事情。
因为它这种偏好是说。
它不是像那种快进快出。
它愿意一下锁定一个。
比如说20年30年的PPP项目。
政府社会资本合作。
锁定这个项目以后。
这个企业决策者
他的经历可以更多发展他其他的爱好。
你想罗宏
动不动跑到非洲
人家是财富自由的人。
对呀？
他一定是有赛场锁定他的财富来源。
他才能这样做
很多人做了PPP以后。
他一下
靠企业锁定跟政府合作。
最长可以40年甚至更长。
这时候他的经历
可以做他自己愿意的。
旅游也好
收藏也好
文艺创新也好
什么都可以
有这种偏好的人
大有人在
或者他开辟新赛道都可以。
有这个潜力的
个人呢？
咱也就是说跟政府合作不上。
你就看能不能
以后介入一些新的机制。
比如说瑞士
是不是可以放开了一颗让居民。
像购买国债一样来购买。
是种类固定收益产品。
可以观察这方面的进步。
所以还是得通过一些投资。
就是要有投资机制的创新。
当然大的底盘还是要强调。
就是大家首先你说的安全感。
伴随着什么呢？
方向感
希望感
坚定不一的贯彻
改革开放大政方针。
不论怎么风云变换。
我们按邓小平说的。
一百年不动摇
一百年是虚数
就是永远不动摇
这条路正确的方向像长期主义。
耐心资本
后边跟着的就敢做这些事了。
你就觉得有不确定性是吧？
就是我问说我怎么能挣更多的钱。
或者是增加自己的安全感。
然后让我未来的预期提高。
然后您给我答案是一百年不动摇。
然后我这样
那是上面的话
那上面话说改革开放。
那改革开放我给你说一个具体的。
有股市资本市场
那么股市上
它就有一些人按重要说。
增加财献收入的机会了。
就是股民现在炒股没有限制吧？
最开始动员领导干部买股票。
后来起来了以后说。
领导干部和执行新入不许炒股。
在我发现没法执行。
所有人都可以炒股。
有些人愿意进去炒股。
虽然说股民作为散户。
一半以上都赚不到钱。
但为什么有人不断的。
还有人进去呢？
还是有机会
意思就是说现在挣钱只能靠炒股了。
我不能只能
我举个例子
就是各种各样的机会。
丰富着
股市上它虽然有种种的副作用。
但它总体来说是一个。
整个市场经济必须有的这么一个机制。
资本市场的健康发展。
对应到什么股权投资。
风险投资
最前沿的是私募的天使投资。
中国的投不齐
靠什么出入出来
不是靠贷款
不是靠一般的政府支持。
最典型的最开始
一飞冲天的马云
靠的是韩译日本人孙正义的。
2000万美元天使投资。
他那时候几轮创新都不成功。
后来准备走互联网家这个创新之路。
他说他自己因为不懂技术。
所以他胆子大
在他那个十八罗汉的那个角色会议上。
他起书
就拍板就得做这个事了。
然后到处求人
谁都觉得他是个骗子。
但他有本事
不到半个小时
缩动了软银的掌门人。
就是那个韩译日本人孙正义。
一个小矮个 兔头。
那个人他就是赶赌付出。
他给了2000万美元天使投资。
结果帮助阿里公司冲过了。
烧钱的最痛苦的阶段。
就是所谓瓶颈期
冲出来以后变成了疯狂上的猪。
没有翅膀也飞冲天了。
马云那时候被人容称为马霸。
宠卖的不得了
那以后他又被人批评那是再往后的事了。
他这个成功有偶然性。
但是在整个的互联网家时代。
前一创新中也有必然性。
就是这种赶赌服输的。
直接的产权清晰化之下。
有这种非政府主体的决策者。
他敢做这种神经特别粗的事。
孙正义他的这个路数就是。
他自己说一般的投资我看不上眼。
我赶赌服输做这个大手笔。
他这个2000万美元成功了以后。
不到两年时间财富规模爆炸式了。
到了接近600亿美元。
差不多3000倍的膨胀。
但是他这种做法在另外一些地方。
大多数都是虚本无规。
他后来在印度有一个大手笔。
最后陈爱洛定注定就不会来了。
他只能是卖掉手上高质量的。
阿利股票去填印度的窟窿。
后来我看到报道说。
他在美国又有几个自己的这种大手笔。
都不行
没想到大模型的AI一来。
其中有一个赛道上。
他一下闲于翻身
他这种承担高失败率。
极低成功率但一旦成功。
全局接货所有成本的成本。
都可能被冲掉的这种投资方式。
不适合我们的银行做。
不适合我们政府主体自己直接上任做。
那么这就是国家多样性。
那资本市场是这样一个。
整个机制它是一个底座。
资本市场分层次
公募的
然后旁边再发展出来私募的。
发展出来现在的
最协议的
这种赶赌服输的投资的力量。
因为咱们之前也聊了说。
我们要不要发放消费券。
或者给底层收入直接补贴。
您觉得因为现在国家的钱。
肯定也是有限的吗？
如果就是同样的这笔钱。
我们是应该优先做。
您说的这种有效投资。
还是说优先直接做消费券。
或者补贴底层人民。
是哪边是更有
这个话说到一个财政的谈话上了。
叫做突出重点
兼顾一般统筹协调。
哎呀？
您这词都一套一套。
因为它整个这个盘子。
政府它财政设计的方方面面。
经济的社会的
它只能是这样
方方面面都能照顾到的情况之下。
还得突出重点
还得阶段性的优化调整。
所以最后表现说
在这么多的阶段里面。
我们不得已要打赤字。
我们赤字的弥补主要要靠发公债。
但是我们现在有底继续在经济的层面上。
我们是在安全区内做这些操作。
我没懂
就是两个事都得干。
就是你赤字率越抬越高。
咱们现在已经抬到4%了。
是吧？
是官方的数据
有人认为更高
但是我们可持续就行了。
所有的发达经济体现在都不会延。
赤字是个政策工具。
而不是简单的
受批评的这么一种错误的做法。
有赤字
弥补赤字在没有结遇和东西的情况下。
就得靠举债
所以举债也是个政策工具。
举债如果说的直白一点。
跟我们老百姓跟我们私人家庭的负债。
看起来一样
没比这个举债的债务都有借有还。
但公债实际上是可以在不断的借新债。
还旧债的过程中间。
把可用的资金越滚越大。
在这个意义上公债不是债。
所以您的意思就是说这两件事。
其实都需要做
但是我们怎么样都做。
就是通过赤字和举债的方式。
还得回到这
你们觉得说得太高大上。
那个统筹兼顾就得综合考虑了。
一个组合的优化设计。